[Music]
hey everybody its Charlie this is gonna
be my video for the ending of fantastic
beasts to crimes of Grindelwald they
made some huge changes or additions I
should say to Harry Potter Canon so I'll
try to explain what they did and how
they're misleading you a little bit I
think they're not giving us the whole
story if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
and obviously careful for spoilers if
you have not seen the movie yep we have
to talk about a couple really big plot
twists so here we go at the end of the
movie Ezra Miller's character credence
is with Grindelwald Grindelwald tells
him his true identity and that's the
huge change introducing a brand new
character that has a lot of big longtime
Harry Potter fans scratching their heads
about how it could possibly exist so
during the movie Grindelwald makes this
big deal about how credence is so
important to him because he's the only
person who can defeat Dumbledore and
Dumbledore is the last thing standing
between him and taking over the world in
the way he tells that story is really
important too he says oh I am certain
he's the only person that can defeat
Dumbledore like he's been sitting on a
really big secret this whole time that
goes all the way back to the original
Harry Potter films when we learned about
Dumbledore's past
he tells credence that his true name is
Elias Dumbledore and he's Dumbledore's
long-lost brother then tells him the
same story about the Phoenix the
Dumbledore told earlier in the film
about how his grandfather told him a
story about how a Phoenix would always
come to a Dumbledore in need so it's a
marker of their family birthright and
evidence that he's not lying about him
being a Dumbledore part of their family
but Grindelwald is slippery he'll say
anything that he wants twist the truth
omit things about the story in order to
get credence to his side so I think he's
only telling a half-truth he is related
to Dumbledore but he's not his brother
so this will make more sense when you
think about the origin story for the
Dumbledore family that you learned
during the original Harry Potter story
but just to clarify the reason why
Grendel Walt needs credence so badly
isn't so much that he's related to
Dumbledore it's because of the obscurest
the obscurest is what makes credence so
powerful any idea how dangerous it is
you're a distraught Dumbledore's brother
you know what to do
where every Center you'll see soon
enough
that's your sister Ariana's inside she
died very young didn't she
my brother sacrificed many things mr.
Bardo on his journey to find power
including Ariana and she was devoted to
him he gave her everything good time
Thank You mr. Dumbledore
so getting into the idea of credence and
where he fits into the Dumbledore family
tree here's the problem we know from
Harry Potter Canon the Dumbledore had
one brother ABBA fourth who he met
during the series and a sister Ariana
Dumbledore there were only three of them
and they're relatively close to the same
age
Dumbledore himself in this movie is
about 30 years older than Creedence so
we just way too old for him to be as
natural born brother
Dumbledore's father actually went to
Azkaban after an incident with his
sister when she was six years old so he
wasn't even around to have another child
with his mother we know though the
Grindelwald spent a lot of time in
Godric's Hollow with Dumbledore when
they were young before Ariana died so
Grindelwald would have known ariana and
everything that was going on with their
family because he was so close with
Dumbledore there was the whole subplot
about the Blood Pact so remember that
Grindelwald and Dumbledore were like
really close allies friends more than
friends as he says and they were
supposed to be the two most powerful
wizards of the age Dumbledore tells a
story during the film when he's talking
to lead a little strange about his
greatest regret was not loving his
sister enough during the original Harry
Potter films Harry Potter learns the
Dumbledore blames himself for his
sister's death because of his
selfishness quick recap about what
happened to Ariana Dumbledore because I
think she's very important to this story
when she was six years old she was taken
advantage of by a couple local muggles
while living in Godric's Hollow in her
rage to get revenge she hoped out on
them with her magic unable to control it
she's a little girl remember she sort of
loses her mind and the Dumbledore's hide
her away from the world for the rest of
her life think about that story though
the way she hooks out loses control of
her magic it sounds a lot like Creedence
in his obscurus so early theory when she
was at
hacked by those boys she developed in
obscurest just like him and that's the
reason why the Dumbledore's hid her away
because it was so dangerous and so
powerful they didn't want to turn her
over because they were afraid that she
would be thrown in Azkaban and she was
just a little girl and they wanted to
protect her later when Dumbledore was
getting ready to finish school he was
supposed to be the next Merlin the
greatest wizard in the history of the
world so he had this bright future ahead
of him but he was also supposed to
become his sister's guardian some time
around then Grindelwald came back to
Godric's Hollow to work with Dumbledore
and compel him to leave with Grendel
waltz so that the two of them could be
together and go pursue greatness because
Grindelwald was also supposed to be one
of the greatest wizards of the age so he
was like come on let's go be great
together were the most powerful wizards
in the world we can do anything that we
want the books state that his sister
died trying to stop a three-way battle
between Dumbledore his brother and
Grindelwald over whether or not
Dumbledore would leave with Grendel wall
to pursue that glory so after she died
soon after he took the job at Hogwarts
and swore off his pursuit of power
because of his great regret like he just
blamed himself for everything that
happened to her so big theory about the
true origin of cretins
I think the credence is actually
Dumbledore's sister's son making him
Dumbledore's nephew he inherited
Ariana's obscurus we also got the flash
back to the boat where Leda Lestrange
swaps her brother with credence in that
crib we see the woman who was caring for
credence we don't know who she was but
she could have been someone working for
the Dumbledore's trying to take Ariana's
son credence to America to keep him safe
but I think the big twist here
especially highlighted by the fact that
the Phoenix appears is that credence is
Dumbledore's blood but not necessarily
his brother there was also this really
creepy subplot with Leda lestranges
father he would use the Imperius curse
on women that he wanted to have children
with once he got the son that he wanted
he cast all the women aside so very
creepy but thematically the idea that
Ariana had a tragic child under
mysterious circumstances that sort of
fits with that but just to be clear if
you haven't read all the Harry Potter
novels there is no mention of Dumbledore
having another brother in the books it
just the three of them they're vastly
older than credence so it just it makes
sense that secretly he's going to be
Ariana's son the big question though is
is that if Dumbledore knew that his
sister had a son then why doesn't he
know about credence maybe he also thinks
that the baby died when the boat sank
but either way I just feel like it's
gonna be a big revelation in one of the
future movies like they're related but
not exactly how you think so let me know
in the comments do you think the
Grindelwald is lying to credence and
he's really the son of Arianna
Dumbledore Dumbledore sister if you guys
didn't know - there's a Wizarding World
TV series that I believe Warner Brothers
is developing for their new streaming
service that will debut sometime next
year I don't know if the Harry Potter TV
show will debut next year maybe 2020 but
the streaming service will debut next
year if we get any more info about that
I will totally do a video what you wait
for everything click here for my
non-spoilery breakdown of all the early
aquaman reviews and click here for my
brand-new Game of Thrones season 8
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight